- Apple just gave its iPhone 14 models
a new Satellite connection.
Ah, okay. We're connected.
If you need help, it can
be used to send a message
to emergency services,
when you don't have cellular
or Wi-Fi connectivity.
To test this, I'm not exactly off grid.
I'm in Prospect Park in Brooklyn,
and Apple gave me this test phone,
where the cellular radio is disabled
so the Satellite connectivity kicks in.
The only thing I needed next,
(dummy squeaks)
an emergency.
While that creates a pretty staged demo,
where little can go wrong, I
still got a really good sense
of how this feature works
and how extremely limited
the feature is compared
to other satellite devices.
Okay, yes let's say fake Joanna falls.
Ready? Bye.
So I call 911, but
there's no cell service.
So instead the iPhone shows this.
An emergency text via satellite button.
When I select that, I get this screen
where I can select from these options.
There are some additional
things to answer too.
Who needs help? Me, always.
Chest pain, traumatic injury, sickness,
stroke, drowning, other.
Traumatic injury.
I can also decide if I wanna
alert my emergency contact.
Now comes the connection
to the satellites,
which in the demos took anywhere
from a few seconds to a minute.
It's looking for a signal.
Okay, I'm gonna turn to the right.
The phone prompts you to move
in different directions
to be better in line with the Satellite,
which if I really did fall,
would be a bit of an issue.
To the right, to the
right like Beyonce says.
(upbeat music)
As soon as it connects, a message
with the information you just filled out
begins to be sent via Satellite.
But here's the interesting thing.
Those messages may not go directly
to emergency services yet.
If your local responders
don't accept text messages,
the message goes to an Apple Relay Center,
where a person will then
relay the information
to local responders to
get you the help you need.
In either case, a dispatcher may ask
for some additional questions via text.
Describe the location of the emergency.
Near a bridge and a path and a tree.
It takes much longer for
the messages to go through
than when on a cellular connection.
So Apple suggests keeping
the messages shorter,
so there's less data to send.
Okay the local responders
have been notified of my fall.
In the case of this demo, Apple
has cut off those messages
from actual emergency workers.
Like any piece of Satellite equipment,
the phone has to be outside
with a clear view of the sky,
so it can connect to a satellite.
Apparently this extra,
I don't know, two feet
doesn't help at all.
In one test, I did run
into a connection issue.
"Uh-oh turn right to find the satellite."
I'm not connected anymore.
It's also more limited than
a dedicated satellite device,
like the $400 Garmin inReach
Mini 2 and the $250 Spot-X.
Those devices let you
contact emergency services,
but also message friends or family.
I miss typing on these so much.
With the iPhone feature,
your emergency contact will be
able to see your conversation
with the emergency dispatcher,
but they can't respond.
The Garmin and Spot-X,
however do require monthly subscriptions.
Apple says this feature is
free for the first two years.
My guess is that Apple's
keeping this feature free
for now because, well,
who would pay for it?
Maybe I would, if I was
frequently in places
without reliable cellular service.
But even then I may opt
for one of these devices
that actually lets me
text family or friends.
I wouldn't be surprised
to see Apple build its
satellite features up over time,
and perhaps make some available for a fee.
For now, like the car
crash detection feature,
this is a cool piece of mind
perk for iPhone 14 owners.
I just wouldn't fall for it.
Smile. You really took
a fall for the team.